es el fin a una relación de 47 años
reino unido y la unión europea-
definieron un histórico acuerdo
comercial y de cooperación post pre
decide el pacto prevé el libre
intercambio de bienes y servicios sin
aranceles ni cuotas aunque con más
restricciones que en la transición una
salida airosa para el reino unido que se
arriesgaba a enfrentar tarifas o luego
de tres décadas en el mercado único el
acuerdo también modifica las reglas en
un área clave la pesca con esta
normativa de la unión europea acepta un
recorte del 25 por ciento de las cuotas
en aguas británicas durante cinco años y
medio estará garantizado el acceso
recíproco a las aguas pero tras ese
periodo las condiciones se definirán en
negociaciones anuales frutas time
shifting semtur y por primera vez desde
1973 seremos un estado costero
independiente con control total de
nuestras aguas con la participación del
reino unido de la pesca aumentando
sustancialmente de aproximadamente la
mitad actual a más de cerca de dos
tercios en cinco años y medio
y esto
el texto contempla que londres y
bruselas mantengan un campo de juego
nivelado con los mismos estándares de
competencia y protección al medio
ambiente
desde el primero de enero de 2021
existirán controles aduaneros en las
fronteras y los ciudadanos no podrán
circular libremente instalarse y
trabajar o estudiar para estancias
superiores a 90 días se deberán
solicitar los visados correspondientes
también se acabarán reconocimientos
mutuos de las calificaciones
profesionales
sé que este es un día difícil para
algunos y a nuestros amigos en
reinounido quiero decirles despedirse es
un dolor tan dulce harting es sachs
sweet
una despedida que tampoco será
definitiva a la cooperación esperada
entre las partes se agrega que el
acuerdo incluye periodos de transición y
cláusulas de revisión lo que vaticina
nuevas negociaciones en el futuro